it starts with reality with martial arts
always started reality it doesn't mean
we cannot be imaginative or all that but
in reality aking and people who break
systems are pretty creative naturally so
we want to inspire ourselves for the
this is a big moment for us in
production basically all the parts of
the game aren't colliding together for
the first time and for the past months
we've been able to play the game from
beginning to end so now we see how
things are coming together and you could
almost say the game has a life of its
own at this point when you finish a game
after almost five years you need to
sleep on it all that then afterwards
what's exciting is when you start really
understanding what you try to do the
first game wow that's good and also what
the players have said so watchdogs was
first of all in you IP which is the big
deal it means that you start from almost
nothing in no IDN wash next one was to
talk about the knife connected society
something that was becoming very
important in our day-to-day lives
Chicago was one of the most surveillance
in North America so we talked a lot
about cameras and surveillance the beat
watch when played watchdogs you probably
played something you never played before
because the city was sort of alive
people were not just people walking
around the street but you can hack into
their lives and they could exploit them
you could see their secrets you could
manipulate the city the bridges and the
steam pipes and the traffic lights
we'll be basically created with
watchdogs one was a playground where
everything was connected
so finally shipping the game a lot of
people were happy and excited we also
got a lot of feedback and we listened to
that feedback
I personally spent months reading forums
and reading all of the player feedbacks
I could see on the web we wanted to know
what people felt that what they wanted
to get from the game and what we could
improve in the future at that point we
knew what we're gonna make a watch next
we felt like we really did a big
milestone with the original watchdogs
but we watched like Stu we could really
deliver on the fantasy of being a hacker
this time around or in San Francisco for
us San Francisco strike the cord because
it meant the very birth of the attitude
of the hackers
Marn houses are calibrated to anticipate
your every
that's bad
but the setting of watchdogs - we wanted
to have a different vibe
so our San Francisco keeps all the
important parts of the Bay Area
there's a different field different vibe
the different looked all of the areas of
our world we wanted to kind of represent
all these different areas and the
different collections of people that
live in these areas and what their
lifestyles and their personalities are
like so we're building a game where
basically it's almost a simulation
you're in that world and if you stop
moving and you look around you feel the
world is alive right this is the promise
of what an open-world game is we broke
the feeling that the world is centered
on you the player so characters
shouldn't only react to you this should
react to each other you know maybe
people start fights
maybe someone calls the cops on someone
else and you maybe a dog barks
after someone else and chases him down
the street you need to feel as if this
city is alive even if you do nothing and
then if you start doing things if you
start playing in the world the city
should react to what you're doing it
should feel normal it should surprise
you also and how it reacts we were
really interested in the city itself it
almost feels like the Wild West of
Technology and how would you know how
can you set something in the Wild West
of Technology
it's a world that has a lot of potential
for game play I mean if you're a hacker
and you go in Silicon Valley and you
have the head office some of the biggest
tech company in the world what will you
do can you hack into those places what
will you find so it's a very intriguing
setting or a hacker who's exploring the
world
so as we're crafting this world we're
putting in it all of the factions that
should be in it so for example we have
various criminal groups trying to fight
over the underground of the city we also
have corporations trying to make money
and potentially even manipulate people
in society and we also have other groups
of hackers trying to tap into the
technology that has been set up in the
city once again CTOs the smart city
system that was in the first watchdogs
is installed in San Francisco and
various people are trying to tap into it
to exercise control power or to try to
make money in creating a hero for
watchdogs too we wanted somebody new
somebody that could embody the spirit of
California and the spirit of San
Francisco but we needed somebody who's
gonna be really worthy of all the cool
stuff that we wanted to do with again
so our hero and watchdogs - is Marcus
Holloway he's a young hacker very
brilliant when what he does because of
the injustice is that he's seen both
being from Auckland and also having been
profiled the wrong way and being accused
of a crime he actually didn't commit
that sort of made him go against the
system
in terms of visual we always try to
create iconic attributes to the
character so that you can be memorable
and people wants to play in but still
feels credible inside our world he's a
perfect blend between somebody that's
tech savvy that represents a bit the
internet culture but also has that
aesthetic and rebellious feeling to him
so we had to decide from the beginning
what things were comparable between
Aidan and the markets and what things
would be different we focused on parkour
we wanted Marcus to be a lot better at
parkour than a team and we're not
talking about just like climbing on
things but like being able to like flow
and chain moves together so he's a
pretty good fighter he's got some
interesting quirks to he's a more
expressive guy we've tried really trying
hard to figure out what kind of melee
weapon Marcus we've had we tried a whole
bunch of things and some things were
pretty cool so these didn't work at all
we did a lot of research and we we
basically did what Marcus would have
done we went onto the internet and we
started watching videos and started
reading websites and try to figure out
what kind of stuff we could make pretty
much all the stuff that you probably
shouldn't search at work in the end when
we stumbled across was this idea of
taking a billiard ball and attaching it
to a paracord lanyard and we took this
and we handed this to the stunt team and
the first thing that we saw was it was
fast it was so fast if we couldn't
believe how fast they were swinging this
around their body and I was as soon as I
saw this video I'm like this is crazy we
got it
citizens of the world may we have your
attention when we say we want to make a
game about hacking really a hacker it's
a culture but you can have various
motivations the motivation were excited
about was what we call hacktivism people
who want to impact society and have
ideals too different so just in the
background and in the fantasy of it
you're not a hacker logics - you're a
dead SEC hacker you're a member of the
community and you're doing grand stuff
and big exposure of important
informations to society because you're
not alone you're working with other
people the first thing that you have to
do when you're talking about hackers is
you kind of have to respect where they
came from originally their messages
sound very serious if there's also a
lousy element to it the way they have
fun with what they're saying we took
that and you said okay so what if this
is the sort of the spirit of dedsec and
of our heroes what if their spirit is
still rooted in the trolling it's a joke
we're gonna have fun with it but they
still have something important to say
that's it middle was really important
for me because it represents everything
that's cool about watchdogs its stylize
it's edgy and it's raw and it's
underground tapping into the origin
tapping into the internet culture with
all the memes and also all the visual
language of the Internet so there are
various characters various people inside
of that set some are a bit more violent
some have more ideals some are maybe
more intellectual but they all have in
common that they want to fight to
preserve a sense of freedom they don't
want people to abuse deck to take
control over people but you know I'm not
saying they are Knights you know they
are they are rebellious they do their
own things there
way and they want to have fun that's
that's also one thing is you know a
sense of freedom also a sense of fun
through that people are dead sick
the new idea for hacking and wash their
stews to let the player create his own
solutions we're adding a lot more depth
to hacking so you have a lot more
control a lot more flexibility in how
you hack the world so one big category
of aking and wash x2 is the entire
branch of pushing remote controls to its
limit one of the big things on wash
times is hacking vehicles I think this
is a real game-changer because vehicles
are everywhere in the world and if you
can hack into the drive system of a car
you can pretty much drive it wherever
you want without making sure if you see
a forklift in the world it shouldn't be
a forklift and just like moons the Box
up-down you should just like a camera
press a button we come that team one of
the core things that we're doing is
we're opening up the game with watchlist
you can hack every character you can
hack every car in the game and you can
hack most of the electronics within the
city so that's a lot of potential
targets for hacking and that's not even
counting your own tools well in
watchdogs 2 we brought in a lot more
toys and things to play with because we
wanted to embrace the maker culture then
SEC have these really interesting
intricate guns they're built on a 3d
printer basically the cutting-edge
technology of 3d printing which is
actually building it with metal
has also got this really cool teaser so
if you want to play the game completely
non-lethal and not actually kill anybody
you can totally do that we're playing
with a lot more crafted items and a lot
more of little devices that you can use
one of the things that people kind of
like that you've done is we've created
toys for Marcus he has an RC jumper
there's got little wheels and it's even
got this little robotic arm that he can
sort of deploy and he can interact with
things he can unplug things and we plug
them in to take out screws that's a neat
little toy and then the other gadget
he's got is this quadcopter and it's
more about scouting and being the eye in
the sky first-person view it is
incredible because you're just zipping
through the city if you looking flying
while you're fighting another branch
which is kind of connected to it as the
concept of manipulating people in
watched x1 you could only hack the
people that were marked as potential
target now you can target the person you
want and you can hack them in multiple
ways for example I could hack one person
and distract them have their phone
ringing so they look at their phone to
create a distraction later on in the
game you also be able to do things we
call mass hacking which is well why only
hack one if you can hack them all
there's one thing that I really believed
about watchdogs players is that there is
no watchdogs player there are many types
of watchdogs players you should be
deciding how you want to play the game
so that means you can play a mission
whole gun blazing if that's the way you
like to play full stealth or through
hacking only project yourself and
computers take control of electronics
influence people and try to get to your
goal that way we try to really support
all players types across all different
styles of play and also a lot of players
to combine and mash these down and play
together too if you've been playing a
certain way for a while we want the game
to kind of challenge you to try as
different things but also not force you
into playing the game server we work to
improve the driving make it more
accessible while keeping all the
different styles of vehicles and adding
a lot of physics and feel to all the
vehicles so we keep the depth but have
more accessibility the team is super
happy with the result we have and I hope
gamers will be just as excited
we are very excited by the potential of
what we call seamless online we start
doing that in watchdogs 1 so we're
expanding on that cross paths with
friends in the city so are you playing
in single-player and you're crossing
paths with another player it was also
playing in single-player both of you are
members of dead sack so your friends and
you can just walk up to each other
you'll say hello hit the button and form
a co-op team and what we're gonna be
showing in the next couple of months
this example of how those things work
together to create magical gameplay
moments the city of San Francisco and
the whole Bay Area is exciting its vast
you're gonna find a ton of things to do
that are unique to you basically build
your own moments you don't create the
situation that you start laughing how
can you say wow this happened and you
want to share it with friends you don't
want to just be like a roller coaster a
big park ride where I go through all the
same beats as everybody else you decide
what you want to be spending your time
doing that can be multiplayer that can
be focusing on stories that can be just
exploring the world
whichever activity you do we're gonna
make sure you get rewarded to get you
closer to the ending that's kind of the
promise or make you to game
you always know when something starts to
click it starts to work everything
changed you stop seeing individual
components animations or texture Maps or
vehicles you just start to see the
experience as a whole it changes on the
floor people get excited about it this
is it it exists we are always making the
game with the player in mind they have
always been the driving force when you
come with a sequel that really burns
it's - you know that really does a lot
of new things that has a lot of
surprises it's a great feeling in the
end there's nothing more accurate than
this looking at something trying to
understand it so lowly for coming up
with the system
click here to join dedsec and receive
exclusive in-game rewards and more
subscribe to our YouTube channel and be
the first to see new trailers and behind
the scenes action